que amenaza nuestra libertad y dignidad en un futuro cercano
la están desarrollando compañías
que se dedican a capturar y vender nuestra información y nuestra atención
a anunciantes y demás:
Facebook, Google, Amazon,
Alibaba, Tencent.
La inteligencia artificial ha comenzado a respaldar esos negocios también.
Y parece que la inteligencia artificial
es lo que le sigue a los anuncios en línea.
Pero no lo es.
Es un salto de categoría.
Es un mundo totalmente distinto,
y tiene un gran potencial.
Podría acelerar nuestro entendimiento
de muchas áreas de estudio e investigación.
Pero, parafraseando a un famoso filósofo hollywoodense,
"Un enorme potencial viene con un enorme riesgo".
Ahora hablemos de un hecho básico de nuestra vida digital: los anuncios.
Como que los ignoramos, ¿no?
Parecen ordinarios, inefectivos.
Todos hemos tenido esa experiencia de ser perseguidos en la web
por un anuncio basado en algo que buscamos o leímos.
Ya saben, buscas un par de botas
y durante una semana, esas botas te siguen a todos lados donde vayas.
Incluso después de haber sucumbido a comprarlas, te continúan siguiendo.
Estamos habituados a ese tipo de manipulación simple y barata.
Ponemos los ojos en blanco y pensamos, "¿Sabes qué? Esto no funciona".
Excepto que, en línea,
las tecnologías digitales no son solo anuncios.
Para entender eso, pensemos en un ejemplo del mundo físico.
¿Han visto que en la caja de cobro del supermercado, cerca del cajero,
hay dulces y goma de mascar a la altura de los ojos de los niños?
Eso está diseñado para hacerlos rogar a sus padres
justo cuando los padres están por pagar.
Eso es arquitectura de la persuasión.
No es agradable, pero funciona.
Por eso se ve en todos los supermercados.
Ahora, en el mundo físico,
la arquitectura de la persuasión es un poco limitada,
porque solo puedes poner unas cuantas cosas cerca de la caja, ¿no?
Y los dulces y goma de mascar son iguales para todos,
aunque en general funciona
solo con la gente que va acompañada de personitas caprichosas.
En el mundo físico, vivimos con esas limitantes.
No obstante, en el mundo digital,
las arquitecturas de la persuasión pueden tener miles de millones de opciones
y pueden apuntar, inferir, entender
y ser aplicadas a cada individuo
uno por uno
descubriendo nuestras debilidades,
y pueden ser enviadas directamente a la pantalla personal de cada teléfono,
así que son invisibles para nosotros.
Y eso es diferente.
Es solo una de las cosas que puede hacer la inteligencia artificial.
Pongamos un ejemplo.
Digamos que quieren vender boletos de avión a Las Vegas.
En el viejo mundo, se dirigirían a ciertos sectores demográficos
basándose en la experiencia y lo que podían suponer.
Podrían tratar de anunciar para
hombres entre los 25 y 35 años,
o gente con un límite alto en la tarjeta de crédito,
o parejas retiradas, ¿no?
Eso es lo que harían en el pasado.
Con big data y aprendizaje automático,
ya no funciona más así.
Así que, para imaginar eso,
piensen en todos los datos que Facebook tiene sobre Uds.:
cada actualización de estado que jamás hayan escrito,
cada conversación en el Messenger,
cada lugar desde donde accedieron,
todas las fotografías que hayan subido.
Lo que comenzaron a escribir y borraron porque cambiaron de opinión;
Facebook guarda y analiza eso también.
Cada vez trata de aproximarse más a los datos de tu vida fuera de línea.
También adquiere muchos datos de los corredores de datos.
Podría ser cualquier cosa, desde registros financieros
hasta una buena parte de tu historial de búsqueda.
En EE. UU. esos datos son habitualmente recolectados,
cotejados y vendidos.
En Europa tienen reglas más estrictas.
Entonces, lo que ocurre es lo siguiente:
al procesar todos esos datos, esos algoritmos de aprendizaje automático,
y por esto se llaman algoritmos de aprendizaje,
aprenden a entender las características de la gente
que compró boletos a Las Vegas anteriormente.
Una vez que aprenden esto de los datos existentes,
también aprenden cómo aplicarlo a un nuevo grupo de gente.
Entonces, si se encuentran con una persona nueva,
pueden clasificar si esa persona compraría un boleto a Las Vegas o no.
Ahora bien, Uds. están pensando:
"Una oferta para comprar boletos a Las Vegas... Puedo ignorarlo".
Pero el problema no es ese.
El problema es
que ya no comprendemos realmente cómo funcionan estos algoritmos complejos.
No entendemos cómo categorizan.
Son matrices gigantes, miles de filas y columnas,
quizá millones de filas y columnas,
y ya ni los programadores
ni nadie que los analice,
aun teniendo todos los datos,
comprende cómo operan exactamente;
no más de lo que Uds. sabrían lo que estoy pensado en este momento
si les enseñaran una disección de mi cerebro.
Es como que ya no estamos programando;
estamos creando inteligencia que no comprendemos totalmente.
Y estas cosas solo funcionan con una enorme cantidad de datos,
así que también fomentan una vigilancia profunda de todos nosotros
para que los algoritmos de aprendizaje funcionen.
Por eso Facebook quiere acumular todos los datos que pueda sobre Uds.
Los algoritmos funcionan mejor.
Así que continuemos con el ejemplo de Las Vegas.
¿Qué pasaría si ese sistema que no entendemos
aprendiera que es más fácil venderle boletos a Las Vegas
a gente bipolar a punto de entrar en un episodio maníaco?
Esa gente tiende a gastar de más y a apostar compulsivamente.
Podrían hacerlo y no tendríamos ni idea de que se fijaron en eso.
Di este ejemplo una vez a un grupo de científicos de la computación
y después, uno se me acercó.
Estaba afligido y dijo: "Por eso no pude publicarlo".
Yo le pregunté: "¿Publicar qué?".
Él había tratado de ver si realmente se podría predecir el arranque maníaco
en publicaciones de redes sociales antes de los síntomas clínicos,
y había funcionado,
había funcionado muy bien,
y no tenía idea de cómo funcionaba o qué había descubierto.
El problema no se resuelve si él no lo publica,
porque ya hay compañías
que están desarrollando este tipo de tecnología,
y muchas de estas cosas ya están a la venta.
Esto ya no es tan difícil.
¿Les ha pasado entrar a YouTube para ver un video en específico
y una hora más tarde vieron 27?
¿Vieron que YouTube tiene una columna a la derecha
que dice: "A continuación"
y que reproduce algo automáticamente?
Es un algoritmo
que elige lo que cree que les interesaría y que quizá no encuentren por sí mismos.
No es un editor humano.
Eso hacen los algoritmos.
Se fijan en lo que han mirado y lo que la gente como Uds. ha mirado,
e infiere que eso debe ser lo que les interesa,
y de lo que quieren más,
y entonces les muestra más.
Parece una herramienta benigna y útil,
excepto cuando no lo es.
En 2016 asistí a actos electorales del entonces candidato Donald Trump
para estudiar, como académica, el movimiento que lo apoyaba.
Estudio los movimientos sociales, así que por eso lo estudiaba también.
Quise escribir algo sobre uno de sus actos,
así que lo miré varias veces en YouTube.
YouTube comenzó a recomendarme
una lista de reproducción de videos de supremacistas blancos
en orden de extremismo creciente.
Si miraba uno,
me llevaba a otro incluso más extremo
y se reproducía automáticamente.
Si miran contenido sobre Hillary Clinton o Bernie Sanders,
YouTube les recomienda y reproduce conspiraciones de izquierda,
de ahí hacia abajo.
Quizá estén pensando que se trata de política, pero no.
No se trata de política.
Es solo el algoritmo entendiendo la conducta humana.
Una vez miré un video sobre el vegetarianismo en YouTube
y YouTube me recomendó y reprodujo un video sobre veganismo.
Uno nunca es lo suficientemente extremo para YouTube.
(Risas)
¿Qué está ocurriendo?
El algoritmo de YouTube está patentado,
pero esto es lo que creo que está pasando.
El algoritmo ha descubierto
que si puedes persuadir a la gente
haciéndoles pensar que puedes mostrarles algo más extremo,
son más propensos a quedarse en el sitio
viendo video tras video adentrándose en el agujero de conejo
mientras Google les sirve anuncios.
Sin alguien a quien le importe la ética de la tienda,
estos sitios pueden retratar gente
que odia a los judíos,
que cree que los judíos son parásitos
y que tiene contenido antisemita explícito,
y permitirte que les envíes anuncios.
También pueden movilizar algoritmos
para encontrar audiencias parecidas,
gente que no tiene ese contenido antisemita explícito en su perfil,
pero a quien el algoritmo detecta como susceptible a esos mensajes,
y te permite enviarles anuncios también.
Esto puede sonar como un ejemplo inverosímil,
pero es real.
ProPublica lo investigó
y encontró que de hecho se puede hacer esto en Facebook,
y Facebook amablemente nos ofreció sugerencias
de cómo ampliar la audiencia.
BuzzFeed lo intentó con Google,
y en seguida vieron que sí, que se puede hacer en Google también.
Y no fue ni siquiera costoso.
El reportero de ProPublica gastó alrededor de 30 dólares
para anunciarle a esa categoría.
El año pasado, el asesor de medios de Donald Trump reveló
que usaban publicaciones de página oculta en Facebook para desmovilizar gente.
No para persuadirlos,
sino para convencerlos de no votar.
Y para lograr eso, se dirigieron a grupos específicos,
por ejemplo, hombres afroamericanos en ciudades clave como Filadelfia,
y voy a leer exactamente lo que dijo.
Cito.
Estaban usando "publicaciones no públicas
cuya audiencia controla la campaña
para que solo la gente que queremos pueda verlas".
"Modelamos esto".
"Esto afectará dramáticamente la habilidad de ella para llevar votantes a las urnas".
¿Qué hay en esas publicaciones de página oculta?
No tenemos idea.
Facebook no nos lo dirá.
Facebook también organiza con un algoritmo las publicaciones
que nuestros amigos ponen en Facebook, o las páginas que seguimos.
No nos muestra todo cronológicamente.
Ordena según la manera en que el algoritmo piensa que nos va a persuadir
para quedarnos más tiempo en el sitio.
Esto tiene muchas consecuencias.
Quizá estén pensando que alguien los está desairando en Facebook.
Pero quizá el algoritmo nunca les muestra su publicación a ellos.
El algoritmo prioriza algunas publicaciones e ignora otras.
Los experimentos muestran
que lo que el algoritmo escoge para mostrar, puede afectar las emociones.
Pero eso no es todo.
También afecta la conducta política.
Así que en 2010, en la votación a mitad de legislatura,
Facebook hizo un experimento con 61 millones de personas en EE. UU.
y lo dio a conocer después.
A algunas personas les mostraron la publicación "Hoy es día de votación",
la más sencilla,
y a otras personas les mostraron la que tiene esa pequeña modificación,
con esas miniaturas
de tus amigos que cliquearon "Voté".
Solo esa pequeña modificación.
Así que las fotos fueron el único cambio,
y esa publicación que fue mostrada solo una vez
añadió 340 000 votantes
en esa elección,
según este estudio
confirmado por los padrones electorales.
¿Suerte? No.
Porque en 2012, repitieron el experimento.
Y esa vez,
ese mensaje cívico mostrado una sola vez
añadió 270 000 votantes.
Como referencia, la elección presidencial de 2016 en EE. UU.
se decidió por unos 100 000 votos.
Facebook también puede inferir muy fácilmente sus opiniones políticas,
aun si nunca las han revelado en el sitio.
Estos algoritmos pueden lograrlo de manera sencilla.
¿Qué pasaría si una plataforma con ese tipo de poder
decide ganar seguidores para un candidato y no para el otro?
¿Cómo lo sabríamos?
Comenzamos en un lugar aparentemente inocuo,
anuncios en línea siguiéndonos a todas partes,
y hemos terminado en otro lugar.
Como público y como ciudadanos,
no sabemos ya si estamos viendo la misma información
o qué es lo que los demás ven,
y sin una base común de información,
poco a poco,
el debate público se está volviendo imposible,
y eso que solo estamos en las etapas iniciales de esto.
Estos algoritmos pueden inferir fácilmente
cosas como el origen étnico de la gente, las ideas religiosas y políticas,
la personalidad,
la inteligencia, la felicidad, el uso de sustancias adictivas,
la separación de los padres, la edad y género,
solo con los "me gusta" de Facebook.
Estos algoritmos pueden identificar manifestantes
incluso si sus caras están parcialmente cubiertas.
Estos algoritmos podrían detectar la orientación sexual de la gente
solo con sus fotos de perfil.
Estas son especulaciones probables
así que no serán 100 % atinadas,
pero yo no me imagino a los poderosos
resistiendo la tentación de usar estas tecnologías
solo porque haya algunos falsos positivos,
lo cual creará, por supuesto, otra oleada de problemas.
Imaginen lo que puede hacer un estado
con la enorme cantidad de datos que tiene de sus ciudadanos.
China ya está usando tecnología de detección de rostros
para identificar y arrestar gente.
Y esta es la tragedia:
Estamos construyendo esta infraestructura de vigilancia y autoritarismo
solo para obtener más clics en los anuncios.
Este no será el autoritarismo de Orwell.
Esto no es "1984".
Si el autoritarismo usa el miedo para aterrorizarnos,
todos estaremos asustados, pero lo sabremos,
lo odiaremos y lo resistiremos.
Pero si la gente en el poder está usando estos algoritmos
para vigilarnos calladamente,
para juzgarnos y empujarnos,
para predecir e identificar a los agitadores y a los rebeldes,
para desplegar arquitecturas de persuasión a escala
y para manipularnos uno por uno
usando las debilidades y vulnerabilidades personales e individuales de cada uno,
y si lo están haciendo a escala
con nuestras pantallas personales
para que ni siquiera sepamos
lo que ven nuestros compañeros ciudadanos y vecinos,
ese autoritarismo nos atrapará como una telaraña
y quizá ni siquiera sepamos que estamos en ella.
Así que la capitalización de mercado de Facebook
se acerca a medio billón de dólares.
Es porque funciona muy bien como arquitectura de persuasión.
Pero la estructura de esa arquitectura
es la misma, sea que vendan zapatos
o sea que vendan política.
Los algoritmos no ven la diferencia.
Los mismos algoritmos utilizados en nosotros
para hacernos más receptivos a los anuncios,
también organizan nuestros flujos de información política, social y personal
y eso debe cambiar.
No me malinterpreten,
usamos plataformas digitales porque nos ofrecen muchísimo.
Yo uso Facebook para estar en contacto con amigos y familia alrededor del mundo.
He escrito acerca lo cruciales que son las redes para los movimientos sociales.
He estudiado cómo pueden usarse estas tecnologías
para eludir la censura en todo el mundo.
Pero no es que la gente que administra Facebook o Google
esté tratando maliciosa y deliberadamente
de polarizar un país o el mundo
y promover el extremismo.
He leído las muchas y bien intencionadas afirmaciones
que esa gente publica.
Pero no son sus intenciones ni las afirmaciones lo que importa,
son las estructuras y modelos de negocio que están construyendo.
Y ese es el meollo del problema.
O Facebook es una estafa gigante de medio billón de dólares,
los avisos en el sitio no funcionan
y no sirve como arquitectura de persuasión,
o su poder de influencia es altamente preocupante.
Debe ser una o la otra.
Es similar también para Google.
Así que, ¿qué podemos hacer?
Esto necesita cambiar.
No puedo ofrecerles una receta simple,
porque necesitamos reestructurar
completamente cómo opera nuestra tecnología digital.
Todo, desde la manera en que se desarrolla la tecnología
hasta la manera en que los incentivos, económicos y demás,
están incorporados al sistema.
Tenemos que encarar y tratar de lidiar con la falta de transparencia
creada por los algoritmos patentados,
el desafío estructural en la opacidad del aprendizaje automático,
todos estos datos sobre nosotros recolectados indiscriminadamente.
Tenemos una gran tarea por delante.
Tenemos que movilizar nuestra tecnología,
nuestra creatividad
y sí, nuestra política,
para que podamos construir inteligencia artificial
que apoye nuestros objetivos humanos,
pero que también esté limitada por nuestros valores humanos.
Entiendo que esto no será sencillo.
Quizá ni siquiera acordemos fácilmente qué significan esos términos.
Pero si nos tomamos en serio
cómo operan estos sistemas de los que dependemos para tantas cosas,
no veo cómo podemos seguir posponiendo esta conversación.
Estas estructuras
están organizando cómo funcionamos
y están controlando
lo que podemos y no podemos hacer.
Muchas de estas plataformas financiadas por anuncios
presumen de ser gratuitas.
En este contexto, eso significa que nosotros somos el producto de venta.
Necesitamos una economía digital
donde nuestros datos y nuestra atención
no estén a la venta para el autoritario o demagogo que pague más.
(Aplausos)
Así que, volviendo a la paráfrasis de Hollywood:
Sí, queremos que el enorme potencial
de la inteligencia artificial y la tecnología digital florezca,
pero para eso debemos enfrentar esta enorme amenaza,
con los ojos abiertos y ahora.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)